jeff how are you
hey pom i'm doing great thanks for
having me on the show absolutely i'm
very excited about this uh first
question i have for you you used to be a
doctor you're not an active doctor
anymore what the hell are you thinking
have you lost your mind what did all
your doctor friends think about you
leaving the profession to go full time
into uh investing in bitcoin
you know what's funny is most people
outside of medicine think i'm crazy
most of my doctor friends are like right
on i wish i had a plan b i wish i had
something i could go into because
healthcare is kind of a rough business
right now uh and and uh you know i've
been planning this for a long time i
started mailshire back in 2013 is when i
founded it so i was doing the two career
thing all the way through um the fall of
2021 uh and just retired then um so what
i've been talking to my doctor friends
about the whole time and they've been
like man that is fantastic like this is
tough medicine is a tough field and
covid didn't make it any better it made
kind of an unhappy situation even worse
so
i personally have no regrets it was a
really fun first career but i'm uh much
more excited about my second career at
this point a career in finance and i'm
having a ball uh vailshare is a ton of
fun bitcoin came along at just the right
time obviously from a financial and
monetary perspective and for my career
as well i when i finally learned about
it and got orange peeled went down the
rabbit hole um it changed my life and it
changed the way i do my investing the
way i think about savings things like
that so i've been having a having a
great time with it talk to me a little
bit about running both careers like most
people in investing would be like hey
this is a full-time career i got to be
fully locked in especially uh in the
bitcoin world where it's 24 7 365 most
doctors and medical professionals like
this full-time career i got to be locked
in i got to be available at all times
how did you balance both of those at the
same time for almost a decade
yeah well like you i'm i'm a i'm a
workaholic i'm i'm super ambitious
to the point of where it's kind of
painful sometimes on my family but i
just work all the time so and i still do
so i i enjoy what i do i'm a big
believer in finding what you're
passionate about and then doing that so
it doesn't feel like work
that's what i do i look forward to every
monday morning i look forward to the day
starting i look forward to the markets
opening i look forward to learning
something new uh the challenge of
investing is kind of like an ongoing
like chess game it just never gets old
the board's always changing it's always
interesting so i just i i'm having a
fantastic time doing it if i can get
paid doing what i love then i'll be the
happiest guy on the planet and that's
where i am right now working two careers
was tough though i'm not gonna lie it
went back in the early days when i was
you know full time working 60 to 80 or
so hours on call every fourth night with
my hospital work um i had to do veil
shower on nights and weekends and any
other free time i could squeeze out i
never took a vacation um so life is a
little bit better now that i've dropped
the medical career i love it uh first
thing i want to talk to you about is uh
is actually recognizing value uh there's
a lot of folks right now especially with
volatility in markets uh across assets
but specifically in bitcoin as well uh
they think that they are day traders hey
you know it's at one price is it gonna
go up a little bit or down a little bit
should i buy should i sell how many
transactions should i do uh you seem to
take a very different approach which is
much more about recognizing longer term
trends finding true value kind of buy
hold and adhere to these timeless
investing principles versus maybe some
of the day trading that happens
why pick that investment strategy and
how do you make sure that you stay with
the idea of recognizing value over a
long period of time versus getting
enticed into into the day trading mania
that has taken place in many financial
markets
yeah well first of all it's really well
documented that day trading just
generally doesn't work as a strategy
over time i think i might be misquoting
this but i remember fidelity putting out
a study a few years ago that said that
the day trading accounts that were
opened uh on their on their system on
their in their brokerage firm within a
year i think 90 percent of those went to
zero or near zero so they basically lost
all their value trick with day trading
is you have to be right more than half
the time and then you have to be right
your winners have to make more than your
losers lose and then on top of that you
have to factor in trading fees so that's
a lot of things working against you and
most people can't do that successfully a
few can by the way um but what i tell
people is to quit especially in regards
to bitcoin uh and other great assets i i
view bitcoin as the king of assets it's
the greatest asset that has ever been
created
instead of trying to time tops and
bottoms which is basically a fool's
errand and even the best professionals
can't do that over and over again they
may get lucky a time or two but in
general you can't do that
learn to recognize value learn to
recognize when something is expensive
and when something is cheap right now
based on all of the metrics that i use
based on on-chain analytics based on
kind of metcalfe's law adoption cycles
those sort of things
bitcoin is super cheap right now could
it get cheaper sure could we go lower
sure if the recession worsens which i
fully expect could bitcoin drop in price
down to fifteen thousand down to ten
thousand below ten thousand sure i don't
care but what i do know right now is
that bitcoin is really cheap and so
learn to recognize value like the the
most famous investors in the world like
the warren buffets those kind of people
when they see value they jump on it
and so i would recommend to people to
quit trying to time the bottom and just
start buying at these prices this is
literally what dollar cost averaging is
made for for this kind of volatility for
this kind of like bottom dwelling price
action if you can just set it and forget
it at a certain dollar amount every day
or every week or every month
i can almost guarantee you that within
two or three or five years you will be
so very happy that you did that today
that you were buying when everybody else
was selling um that's the way to get to
grow wealthy over the long run so i hope
people are taking advantage of these
prices right now in bitcoin when you
start to look at various asset classes
are you all bitcoin and that's what you
spend all of your time thinking about or
do you look at other asset classes as
well and how do you select
kind of markets to analyze and
participate in versus the difference of
like the security selection itself so
hey i should go and look at stocks
versus an individual stock and spending
your time like where do you spend most
of your time uh on the analysis front
yeah so great question so when i started
my career i actually started writing for
motley fool and seeking alpha way back
in the early 2010s i was a stock picking
analyst i focused mostly in the
healthcare and technology sectors then
bitcoin came along and then on top of
that what i realized it took me a while
but by the end of the 2010 so 2017 2018
2019 i just finally figured out that you
know what value investing is not working
right now growth is the growth is the
only game in town right now so basically
if you had growing revenues you didn't
even need to have positive earnings you
barely had to have any kind of cash
flows you just needed a revenue growth
in order to be a favorite favored stock
in the market
that was kind of the way the the world
was working at that point so i sort of
morphed my strategy i'm a top-down macro
guy so i i tend to see the world in
terms of what is inflation doing what
are economic cycles doing
what is the fed doing what are other
central banks doing different asset
classes respond in kind to these kind of
factors based on what inflation things
are doing so that causes currencies to
fluctuate that causes interest rates to
move higher or move lower when interest
rates move higher lower that has a
significant effect on other things like
financials like energy like commodities
and so i tend to look across everything
now i have i i tried to be kind of a
jack of all trades um and then i i've
sort of focused in on bitcoin itself so
yes i'm hardcore on bitcoin i focus a
lot of my education on bitcoin i love to
spend time on twitter spaces teaching
people about it um but i do focus both
in my hedge fund and in my separately
managed accounts for my clients we're
into equities we're into bonds if bonds
are a good thing to be into they aren't
right now uh currencies commodities you
name it um if i think we can generate
alpha in that sector we'll be in it so
when you start to evaluate these various
markets how long is your time horizon is
this like hey i look at one week one
month one year a decade like how do you
actually analyze what
constitutes good value over your time
period
in my mind i'm still a long-term
investor i want to hold things forever
like so personally i hold my plan on
holding bitcoin forever and hopefully
never selling it right my mantra is
until i can live off of five percent of
my bitcoin savings i'll never touch it
so that's my goal whatever whenever that
happens it'll happen and even then i may
not sell it i may just borrow against it
but that's a different story
in my mind i'm a long-term investor but
i also make my trading decisions and i
have a whole kind of trading system that
i have built for valshar where i use
momentum uh and volatility uh to factor
in when i'm in and out of positions and
so like right now for example i you know
i've been bearish from a macro point of
view since early january and been
telling people like look out it's going
to get ugly
back in january february march i'm like
we haven't even hit the rough patch yet
from a macro standpoint now we're in the
rough patch now we're seeing what
happens to markets when things get
really ugly i think a recession is
inevitable in fact i think we're
probably already in a recession right
now and i think it's going to get much
worse before it gets better so when i
invest in different assets
i use momentum clearly we're in a
bearish
formation right now momentum is very
very strongly bearish now nothing goes
straight down just like nothing goes
straight up what it does when it goes
down is it zigzags down so i use that
form of trading i'll be i'll have a very
macro bearish view that things are going
to go in this downward channel but
within the channel we may get up to kind
of higher points in the volatility range
at that point i'll increase my shorts
i'll take profits when we get to the
lower end of our volatility range and i
just kind of do that over and over again
um so i'm i'm i'm like a long-term
investor but with with trading
strategies mixed in there so it's kind
of hard to pin me down you mentioned
that uh you believe we're already in a
recession we obviously saw uh gdp
contract in q1 uh we have the white
house press secretary saying that there
is no recession imminent they don't see
any signs of recession you see janet
yellen also saying that she doesn't
believe a recession is imminent and no
one needs to worry at the moment uh what
is the difference between your view of
the world and their view of the world
why do you think we're already in a
recession
i think the difference is i'm being
honest right i'm being intellectually
honest i'm not managing the expectations
of the country like those guys are i
think that's the primary job of the
federal reserve by the way is to manage
expectations of the markets um and
because expectations are everything and
if you lose your perspective on
something and if you go crazy then then
that's when things plummet and get out
of control so i think they want to sort
of maintain
the um concept that they actually do
exert significant control over the
markets and in a way they do but in a
more powerful way they don't the markets
themselves are so much more powerful and
so much larger than the fed itself um
but so so what are they doing i think
they're being not totally honest they're
twisting the truth they're focusing on
things like well unemployment is still
very low that's true but that's going to
change probably pretty pretty rapidly
everything else you look at whether it's
consumer sentiment whether it's housing
rolling over whether it's the stock
market crashing you can go on thing
after thing manufacturer uh
manufacturing is way down i mean we're
talking not just recessionary levels
some things are at all time historic
lows right now that is not good the ceos
that were interviewed this just study
came out i'm sure you talked about this
too 75 percent of ceos think that we're
either in a recession or we're going to
be in a recession within the next 12
months
that's for real that's no joke right and
as stan drunken miller has pointed out
in the past when you have a high dollar
valuation high oil prices and high
interest rates that always leads to an
earning recession for companies this
stuff is still coming we haven't even
hit this part yet so we haven't hit the
ugliest part of everything right now the
one thing that i'm watching by the way
really closely is the price of oil oil
has been uh kind of on a downtrend
recently and i think that it probably
has peaked and it's rolling over
similar to 2008 the stock market had
started to decline but the price of oil
had continued to ramp up higher once you
see that price of oil peak and then
descend it can descend extremely quickly
and what that does is the floor drops
out of risk on assets stocks i think
risk on assets in general are going to
crash and probably crash hard and
further than they have already and then
at that point that's when we'll get the
disinflation right the disinflation that
paul wants he's hoping for he's gunning
for demand destruction
he's succeeding he's destroying demand
he's bringing down um the the wealth
effect he's making people poor he's
shutting down businesses he's uh he's
getting what he what he uh wants and i i
think we should be careful to um uh to
be careful about what we're wishing for
because we're gonna get it and it's
gonna be ugly in the short term
obviously he has uh doubled and tripled
down on uh his promise to increase
interest rates we saw 75 bases point
hike uh with the last hike and um it
feels like uh many people in the market
are like hey man no moss like we've
already seen demand destruction we've
already seen the economic contraction
but they remain committed to raising
interest rates even further uh they're
going to continue with the quantitative
tightening uh what is your read on their
ability to actually follow through with
what they're saying given the
contracting economy given asset prices
down already so much is this just
inevitable that they will push us into a
full-on recession and people should
brace for that or will we see the
federal reserve wave the white flag give
up and kind of reverse course out of
necessity because their demand
destruction is almost too good and
people start getting really really hurt
by it
uh i think kind of all of the above i
think that they will wave the white flag
at some point and they will pivot and go
dovish again and that that's definitely
coming but first we need lots of pain
and i think they're going to succeed i
believe paul when he says that they are
not going to stop their tightening their
hawkish stance until they see
significant sustained disinflation
i think he's going to get what he asks
for and it's going to be really ugly and
again i think that the markets have a
lot further to fall they they started at
extremely high historically high
valuations from a price of sales price
to earning perspective basically any
metric you use was kind of similar to
you know
1929.com bubble 2008 those kind of
levels that's where we were um and we've
come down a lot from there but there
still is much further to fall i would
not be surprised to see you know the
nasdaq fall another 30 40 from here
maybe even 50 from here um that would be
um not not surprising and i think that's
the point where the fed would pivot they
would find and we would definitely be
seeing disinflation and if not outright
just deflation at that point um that's
going to be ugly i don't i don't wish
that on anybody i really recommend that
people consider hedging or at least
holding larger cash positions at this
point because i still think there's more
ugliness to work through before the fed
pivots back to michigan real quick if i
can put on my conspiracy theory hat one
thing that i think the fed is trying to
do is move as fast as possible uh that's
why they're raising rates at kind of an
unprecedented rate and i think they're
they're very vocal about what they're
doing about wanting to destroy demand
about realizing that it's going to be
sacrificing the stock market as well as
the housing market things like that i
think they want all of this to happen so
that we can bottom and then they can
pivot and turn back on to uh to qe or at
least to pause before the midterm
elections i think they can't go into
midterm elections with inflation still
high and with stocks still falling they
need to try to have this happen very
quickly probably this summer crash and
burn so that then they can bottom and
then turn everything back on again and
get assets kind of going back up again
before the midterm elections that's my
conspiracy theory i'm not political at
all i don't care at all but as it stands
right now the democrats are toast right
because if you go into a midterm
election with the economy down and
inflation high um it's just going to be
an absolute landslide for the
republicans as far as i view it when you
mentioned cash having a larger cash
position uh many people over the last
two years but hey inflation's coming now
inflation's here it's very high it's the
40-year kind of historic levels um
but also asset prices are falling and so
how do you balance uh the risk of
getting out of cash into assets that may
just be going down versus uh the known
factor of inflation is high and you're
losing purchasing power in the cash like
how do you kind of think through that
problem and maybe there isn't anywhere
to hide
yeah it's all about time frames right so
in the short term when things are ugly
in the near term um you want to go to
cash why because cash the us dollar
specifically is the world's safe haven
asset that's where people go why do they
go there it's because when you have your
stocks or your bonds or your commodities
or even your cryptos or your bitcoin or
whatever you have what happens people
panic they see things getting ugly they
see lots of red candles they hit sell
sell sell sell sell and what happens
when you sell those things you go into
cash you're buying us dollars it becomes
a safe haven asset so what we see in
these times of intense market fear
during times of uh you know recessions
like we're entering into
the the the valor the value of the us
dollar relative to all other currencies
goes up that's why we've been seeing the
dixie rise and go as high as it has i
think it's going to go higher still
before this is over for sure
the second point of this though is that
the dollar is a terrible asset to hold
for the long term so short term it's a
great asset to hold when we're going
through a correction long term it's
terrible right it's guaranteed to
devalue over time you're guaranteed to
lose your purchasing power over time
that's literally the monetary policy of
the dollar is to inflate and to print
more of it and to cause your uh
purchasing power to decrease over time
for the benefit of the government for
the loss of uh us citizens so get out of
the u.s dollar over the long run but but
consider it in the short term when you
think about uh asset prices continue to
go down and kind of this very bearish
view in the short term kind of this
crash and burn of stocks how would you
anticipate bitcoin to participate uh
alongside and we've obviously seen a
high correlation bitcoin just hit its
all-time high correlation with the s p
500 nasdaq's very high as well is it
just wherever stocks go bitcoin's going
or do you expect to have some decoupling
and maybe bitcoin could serve as a safe
haven compared to a short-term outlook
for stocks or other assets
so yes the correlation with the stock
market has been you know
uncontrovertible it's just it just has
been what it has been why is that i
think for now it really comes down to
education
even though you and i and most people
listening to this understand that
bitcoin is actually the world's greatest
safe haven asset and savings technology
that has ever been created and i think
ever will be um most people don't view
it that way most people you think of it
either like it's just a crypto or they
think of it like a small tech stock they
don't understand the difference between
bitcoin and a tech stock or bitcoin and
crypto um and so they don't rec they
don't recognize what it is that they're
holding so until the majority of market
participants start to understand what
bitcoin is that it truly is just simply
better money for a better world uh that
it is the world's ultimate safe haven
asset things like that at that point it
will continue so over the long run more
and more people will recognize that it
will become the world's ultimate safe
haven risk off asset um for now it still
trades like that although i will tell
you that i think that most of the
decline is already priced in could it go
lower sure um but i think we've seen
most of the worst of it i also think
that bitcoin is the canary in the coal
mine
it's it's the world's freest market so
it tends to respond the most quickly to
changing economic and inflationary
conditions bitcoin peaked i think back
on november 8th of 2021 and then since
then has been declining it was the first
to sense or smell trouble underneath the
hood uh of the economic engine
throughout the world and i think it's
going to be the first to sniff that
things have maybe bottomed and were and
were going to enter a period of
of uh more risk-on
a more risk-on environment going forward
so i'm watching bitcoin very closely i
think that it will decouple at some
point
and and when it starts to peak when it
looks like a bottom has been formed
that will be a fantastic time and i
think it's going to lead to you know two
or three or more years of really
fantastic price performance
definitely outperforming equities
definitely outperforming other asset
classes when you start to think about
the fed uh do they care about asset
prices
will they actually waive the white flag
because of the asset prices or is it
true that they are only looking at
inflation
that's a tough one
well first of all i think you know even
though they're supposed to be apolitical
they were clearly influenced by trump
right powell was you know trump was like
get the stock market up get the stock
market up get the stock market up do
whatever it takes and i think biden is
the exact opposite like get inflation
down get inflation down get inflation
down and so they're kind of they they
sort of um shift
direction based on the current
administration i think their primary
focus i think it's legitimate that their
their primary focus is inflation but i
think they definitely care about falling
asset prices they realize that their
popularity is definitely based on this
as well as their job security they're in
a tough bind right now right because
they're not completely responsible for
this inflation that we're experienced a
lot of this is supply side
that they can't control so because the
supply demand equation is out of balance
the only solution they have is to
destroy demand um and which is a
terrible solution right that's like a
socialist response to how do you how do
you make the world like if the things
are out of balance what do you do you
make everybody miserable that's
literally what they're doing right now
you know i think a smart plan would be
let's raise supply let's free up supply
chain issues all this other kind of
stuff let's increase oil production
let's help resolve the russia ukraine
war blah blah blah and raise the
standard of living for everybody instead
we're doing the opposite we're bringing
everybody down and making everybody
miserable to solve this imbalance um
they definitely are concerned about
asset prices but they're pretending to
look the other way for now um at some
point it will just become too serious uh
of a problem and they're going to have
to switch and that's when they'll pivot
and i think that's when the the next
asset bubble will uh start i do think by
the way qe4 is going to absolutely dwarf
qe one two and three combined so as i
said get ready for that buckle up for
what's next for for the lower prices but
then buckle up for the asset inflation
after that it definitely feels like
there's just this trend of uh the easy
free money leads to these bubbles
there's kind of a popping of them uh we
get a crash back or kind of a reversion
to the mean and then it's like oh [ __ ]
everything's crashing let's inject more
liquidity uh and when we go and do that
we just get a bigger and bigger bubble
over time what's the end state like
is it unsustainable and eventually they
can't keep doing it or does it literally
just get bigger and bigger uh and one
day the united states takes zeros off of
the dollar uh and says you know no big
deal everyone just keep uh normal
operations going
i think the end state is the collapse of
the dollar but i think that's a long
ways away so so i i see this decade as
basically a decade of stagflation with
occasional deflationary busts
that are just going to be terrible so so
as as you were just saying so we're
going to see these massive qes these
massive bubbles being formed and then
okay we're overheating popped you got to
pop the bubble everything crashes down
you know similar to kind of how the 70s
were where it was just massive choppy
action but basically from 1966 to 1982
stock places were flat so if you had
just like not invested in you know or or
put your money in stocks and then fallen
asleep for 16 years you would have had
the same stock value at the end of 16
years now mind you that would be minus
uh the the inflation that you lost the
loss of purchasing power so you actually
got kind of uh destroyed during that uh
those 16 years i think we're kind of due
for a same uh setup and it's just going
to continue until people start losing
confidence in the currency
i like to steal a quote from greg foss
by the way i'm sure you know him
who talks about the u.s dollar being the
best crack house on the crack street the
u.s dollar will definitely be the last
to fall i think in the meantime lots and
lots of other currencies smaller
currencies are actually going to go away
this decade we're already starting to
see that and i think that purchasing
power is going to go into one of three
currencies over the next 10 years i
think the dollar is still going to
achieve some of the gain some of that
purchasing power i think the chinese
yuan whether people love or hate china
it is definitely on the ascent and i
think that currency will gain strength
and i think the third is bitcoin and i
think that's going to gain massively in
market cap over the next 10 years so i
would be watching for that and i think
by you know 10 years from now we're
basically only going to have these main
three currencies and people won't really
be discussing other currencies including
the japanese yen including even the euro
other strong currencies i think they're
basically going to be um irrelevant i
hate to say that to you know
pro-european people and pro-japanese
people but um i think the currencies are
are weak and getting weaker and that's
going to happen faster than most people
realize is there a world where uh the
individuals who share the same view as
you uh not only quote go long on the
dollar uh bitcoin and uh and china but
also they would short the weaker
currencies that likely would fail so
kind of go long the strength go short uh
the weak ones or
is it more of a strategy of like hey
it's really hard uh to kind of time and
understand the severity of the weakening
of these currencies and so people are
better off kind of just looking at the
the long um articulation uh and not play
around so much with the shorts
i think the easiest way to play that for
shorting fiat currency is just going
long bitcoin right i mean just this is
the monetary policy of bitcoin because
it's perfectly scarce because of uh you
know the the inherent designs and
properties of bitcoin it's designed to
go up in value over time it's designed
to appreciate in value over time
government fiat currency literally is
going to all government fiat currencies
go to zero that's just what they do
that's what they're designed to do
whether people admitted it or not and so
i don't like trading individual
government fiat currencies against each
other because they're all racing towards
zero and it's just kind of a matter of
well you know what policy is shifting
what and you can make money on the short
term but to me that's a very difficult
trade and hard to be profitable
consistently on those it's very easy i
think it's in fact i think it's the
trade of the decade all you got to do is
trade uh fiat currency for bitcoin which
is designed to appreciate over time and
it's almost like you can't go wrong
that's that's how i view it i think it's
definitely going to be the world's
reserve currency at some point it will
absorb the purchasing power of other
government fiat currencies so don't even
worry about the trading and especially
by the way one one quick piece because
they're both designed right the dollar
is designed to depreciate in value over
time but in the short term it's very
strong
uh uh on the contrary bitcoin is
designed to appreciate in value over
time but in the short term it's very
weak it's down like 70
trade your strong dollars for your weak
bitcoin for for a long term investment
strategy and it's hard not to do well if
you do that i've heard you previously
say that bitcoin is kind of perfect
money and that this was unattainable uh
in the analog gauge but it is attainable
in the digital age what do you mean by
that
i like to give credit to gold for being
a fantastic stable store of value for
the analog age so basically the last
three thousand four thousand years gold
did a great job of being a stable store
value in fact you can look at some
studies that show you could buy the same
amount of food and wine back during the
roman empire you know so the time of
christ 2000 years ago or so about
exactly the same amount of gold would
buy you the same amount of food back
then as it does today that's pretty
remarkable that's a fantastic stable
store of value it wasn't until the
digital age came around and we're
clearly entering into the digital age
some old timers you know a lot of
boomers have a difficult time
understanding that getting their kind of
arms wrapped around that their mind
wrapped around that but we clearly are
right we're entering into the digital
age so it wasn't until the digital age
came to fruition and became a reality
that we could actually design a more
perfect money so bitcoin excuse me so
gold was a fantastic stable store of
value bitcoin is everything that gold
was plus some so everything that gold
does well bitcoin does at least that
well and actually does many of those
things 10x or 100x better
that's why i think it is a near perfect
money i say near perfect because it's
still not a great medium of exchange
that is changing quickly as layer 2
layer 3 gets built out as as the
lightning network expands and becomes
ubiquitous throughout the world then i
think it will be essentially a perfect
money it's the perfect base layer of
money with some kind of you know
ugliness on top right now that will get
built out it will become much easier to
use um it's just a it's a perfect store
of value it's basically guaranteed by
design to appreciate in value over time
because of its perfect scarcity and
decentralized nature and all these kind
of things it will to me it's just
obvious and inevitable that it will
become the world's money at some point
um but it's going to take some time to
get there when you start to think about
bitcoin being adopted globally we've
obviously seen individuals first then
we've started to see organizations over
the last three or four years both
financial institutions
uh public companies private companies
now we're starting to see nation states
be interested we've got el salvador
who's openly buying bitcoin they've
built out a bunch of infrastructure
we've seen some other countries start
talking about it is your expectation
that some of these countries will drop
their fiat currencies for bitcoin or do
you believe that they will just add
bitcoin somewhere to el salvador as
legal currency alongside either their
own native currency or another legal
currency that they already are using
i think at least in the next couple of
years they're going to pull the el
salvador model i think we're going to
see this hybrid model which is clunky
and kind of ugly but you know el
salvador are still kind of holding on to
to the old system they still have to
cling to the us dollar system there are
a lot of kinks to work out in the
meantime until the bitcoin
infrastructure gets built out so it's
super easy to use until it's as easy to
use it as it is to you know break out
your visa card and buy a starbucks with
it those kind of things and that's
coming
until all of these kind of issues are
ironed out i think we're going to see
this hybrid model maybe three four five
years from now we'll start seeing the
first nation state go to just simply
bitcoin on a bitcoin standard um there's
going to be kinks that's going to be a
little bit ugly this decade in general
but it's growing exponentially and the
adoption um and the usability of bitcoin
is also growing exponentially and so uh
i think it's going to happen sooner than
most people think
when you start to think about uh bitcoin
today one of the things that i always go
back to is like the longest term
investors the pensions the endowments
the foundations they have permanent
capital to some degree
but many of them have fixed income and
they're at a real negative rate of
return is your expectation that we're
going to see all these long-term
investors eventually get up the
education curve and they will start to
allocate very large portions of their uh
portfolios to bitcoin because of that
long-term uh kind of compounding nature
of the asset
yes well first of all bonds are the most
obvious stupid investment of this decade
right i mean you they there's no way
they're going to keep up with inflation
um they may make good short-term trade
so i'm not like 100 anti-ownership of
bonds there are times where bonds are
good in fact we may see one if oil drops
and we and we head into a recession at
some point people are going to flock
into u.s treasuries and they'll probably
do well on a short-term perspective um
so the these companies these huge punch
pension funds endowments things that
that have you know 60 40 or more or a
higher percentage of bond allocation
than 40
they're definitely already talking about
bitcoin they're already talking about
their terrible returns um it's really
hard to change these systems these guys
have been doing what they've been doing
very successfully since the early 80s
it's been a great strategy to be long
bond so it takes a lot and a lot of
committee meetings and a lot of ringing
of hands and you know and conferences
and things
to get people to switch their policies
but it absolutely will come i think it
starts really small that's one thing
that i'm looking for by the way i'm
waiting to see um these sorts of
entrants into the bitcoin space i think
what we've seen so far from an
institutional perspective
are trading hedge funds and and similar
funds um that love to go long and short
bitcoin they love to trade bitcoin
because of its volatility these are not
who we really want in the system to grow
the network what we really want are the
long-term toddlers you know the the
people who buy a company and they hold
it for 10 20 50 years or more
those are the kind of committees that we
want talking about bitcoin we want these
endowments and these kind of funds to to
that are long only essentially to buy
bitcoin i think they're going to start
out small they might start out with a
one percent allocation but that will
that will rise over time especially as
the lawn as the losses on their bond
purchases
start to mount start to build up over
time and inflation continues to be
generally high this decade they're going
to realize like we are just literally
throwing purchasing power away we're
losing so much money with these bonds we
need to go heavier into bitcoin
so i think that's coming i think it's
going to take though many many years
until that's a common thing and not too
scary for a lot of these
traditional pension funds and endowments
talk to me about some of the public
market
investment vehicles we obviously have
seen the bitcoin futures etf get
approved in the united states we now
have a bitcoin short futures etf uh we
still don't have the bitcoin spot etf
how important are these vehicles for
institutions or other investors to get
exposure versus they're nice to haves
but really if people want exposure
they're going to go and buy the actual
asset themselves
i think for a retail investor they're
sort of a non-issue right they're a
nothing burger for the most part i think
most retail investors should avoid the
futures based etfs they're just they're
inefficient they're terrible in general
um so i would say stay away i think what
that means though is that this is the
inevitable adoption of bitcoin it's it's
it's wall street building out its
infrastructure and accepting bitcoin as
a new asset class so in that way it's a
good thing i think it's going to bring
in large amounts of money like billions
of dollars into bitcoin because of these
sorts of products um it's inevitable too
so a lot of the traditional you know the
original cypherpunks and the you know
not your keys not your coins bitcoiners
they don't like this kind of stuff they
don't like seeing uh wall street getting
its tentacles uh into bitcoin but it's
again i think it's inevitable and it's
what will bring bitcoin from being kind
of a 1 trillion or sub 1 trillion asset
class
asset
up to you know 10 trillion 50 trillion
100 trillion in the coming years
it needs to be adopted by wall street we
we're going to see all of these types of
products
it's frustrating for many that the spot
bitcoin etf hasn't yet been approved
it's sort of a head scratcher when you
see and i understand the reasons right
the cme is responsible for futures based
things
and it's it's just it's a different kind
of structure i know gary gensler is
being very um uh slow and
reluctant as far as this adoption it is
coming at some point it is inevitable so
so uh once that happens i think there is
a wall of money that is going to enter
the space um because it's such an easy
way to invest in bitcoin even though
it's it's sort of a it's sort of a
derivative of bitcoin it's still a very
easy way for people to get their 401ks
and their iras into bitcoin it's a great
product that that will be approved at
some point i hope it's sooner than later
but i'm not holding my breath anymore
i'm just kind of waiting to see what uh
the sec decides yeah that makes sense
let's talk about taxation uh the united
states is treating bitcoin as property
today and so if i go and i spend it i
get hit with capital gains taxes um is
that a barrier to bitcoin adoption or do
you expect over time there to be some
sort of like de minimis uh exemption or
some way to encourage more people to
actually spend bitcoin and have it
transitioning from just a pure store of
value to uh much more of a medium of
exchange and maybe even a unit of
account uh as uh more and more people
adopt it
yeah i think it's inevitable that i
think it's a mistake right now it's fine
in its early days to consider it a
property you know the irs and the us
government in general had no idea how to
how to characterize bitcoin um so they
called it a property and that's fine for
the most part but yes it's a huge
hindrance for people people don't want
to spend their bitcoin if they're going
to incur a capital gains tax every time
they buy a starbucks or whatever um that
is again inevitable to me that i think
at some point within uh i hope it's as
early as five years but probably more
like 10 years down the road i think that
the government changes its stance and
they officially basically admit that
bitcoin is a currency that it is a money
and they start treating it and taxing it
as such so i'm looking forward to that
dave when people can just sort of freely
spend it like they would us dollars uh
and and you know the purchases will get
easy at that point the lightning network
i expect to basically be ubiquitous i
expect uh transactions on bitcoin to be
extremely easy um also at that point i
think it will be a wonderful unit of
account too it'll be much more stable i
don't think we're going to see these 10x
100x 1000x games that we're seeing sort
of in the early days of bitcoin um but
then by that point it will be a
fantastic uh money it will be kind of
widely regarded as the world's best
decentralized apolitical money and
people will be one by one kind of as we
were talking about earlier they're going
to be putting away their current
government fiat currencies and putting
their purchasing power into bitcoin
and then it will be just used for
commerce around the world without people
even thinking about it what's the one
milestone that you look forward to in
the future that maybe people aren't
putting as much importance on that
you're like this is going to be really
important when it happens i just don't
know when it will occur
that's actually one of them kind of how
the government characterize it you know
the most important thing for me what i
had been watching for was for it to
become a primary central issue for the
government that we would be hearing
headlines we'd hear politicians debating
it talking about it on a regular basis
we've already reached that point so
that's pretty fantastic i think the next
is
is is is to see countries bigger than el
salvador start to adopt it right
russia's talking about accepting bitcoin
and crypto as payments for for their
goods um that's also a great start um
what i want to see you know i'll tell
you what would floor me and what i think
would be awesome so everybody's been
paying attention to the japanese yen and
the collapse of it and and and their
yield curve control that they're doing
all this kind of stuff
i think japan could be a dark horse and
if they were smart if there was just one
person who understands bitcoin you know
in their government high up enough that
they could whisper into the ears of
people like look this could be our way
out of this can you imagine if a
government a g7 nation started printing
money uh you know printing money and
using the proceeds to buy bitcoin and to
use that as a store of value use it as a
treasury reserve asset like we have with
gold in the past gold was a fantastic
reserve asset for the analog age bitcoin
is clearly the best asset for the
digital age
that could be a dark horse that would
literally just rock the world and so i
would love to see that headline come out
that a g7 nation is actually holding
bitcoin as a treasury reserve asset that
would be a game changer
when you start to think about um kind of
bitcoin what is the
conversation right now with investors
it's drawn down 70
uh there's plenty of people who are
doing their victory laps who have been
critics they're saying it's over uh many
of them were the same people in 2018
that were saying it's over uh but what's
the conversation like with clients
around bitcoin now and how many of them
actually think that it could be over how
many of them are simply saying oh wow
this is a much lower price than it was
just a few months ago and therefore
they're excited
my clients are surprisingly relaxed
about it you know there's a couple that
went like kind of all in um on their own
and i always tell them if you want to do
that kind of stuff on your own once you
feel like you have a good handle a good
grasp of bitcoin you know here's how you
do it here's how you buy it here's how
you put it in cold storage those kind of
things they're freaking out a little bit
they don't like watching their their net
worth decline uh that's that
substantially i would say the vast
majority of my clients are just kind of
taking this in stride like yeah this is
what happens what i remind people too by
the way bitcoin's been in the limelight
and like you know peter schiff comes out
and talks about oh bitcoin has failed c
it's going to zero blah blah blah look
shopify is down more than bitcoin is
down and shopify is a fantastic company
i don't hear anybody talking about
shopify being tulips being tulip mania
being a failed experiment that shopify
is going to zero that's just ludicrous
to talk like that and so it's ludicrous
to talk about bitcoin that it's a failed
experiment because it's down so much yes
it's extremely volatile everybody knows
that but look we're in we're literally
in or entering into one of the worst
recessionary periods
of our country's history it's going to
be painful for all asset classes even
ones that have held up pretty well
they're going they're still going to get
tanked we're still going to see oil i
think tank it may drop 70 or 80 percent
be from from its highest uh before this
is over so nobody's gonna talk about oil
being a failure right nobody's gonna
talk about oil being tulip mania so to
me that's all ridiculous the only people
who say stuff like that are people who
don't understand bitcoin at all they
just don't get what it's for they don't
understand that it's simply better money
um so i don't i don't put much talking
about my clients i've been teaching them
about it since i i got orange peeled
back in 2019 and uh you know what did it
for me was safety dean's book the
bitcoin standard just kind of
understanding the history of money and
why bitcoin is basically the best money
um once i started to understand that i
started to teach my clients that so long
story short they take it all in stride
we're doing fine
when i tell people that they should go
follow you on the internet where can i
send them or where can they find out
more about valshare
sure if you want to learn more about how
i manage money i obviously do my um ria
my separately managed accounts different
than most people i'm not like a
traditional investment advisor or
financial planner i run my client my
separately managed accounts more like my
hedge fund so if you want to learn more
about that you can check out
valeshire.com or actually just shoot me
an email info veilshire.com and then i
spend most of my days actually on
twitter my handle is at veilshirecap
i'm on there probably too much uh so
feel free to follow me on there i'm on
twitter spaces a lot i love to talk
about bitcoin and markets and investing
and all that so uh feel free to look me
up awesome man jeff thank you so much
for taking the time to do this uh it is
pretty incredible that you built this
all while also uh being a doctor and uh
i wish that uh more people could see
that there's a path to work hard do it
for a long period of time and uh and you
can get yourself in a position that
you're in um and uh just talking to you
today it's very obvious that uh you care
about this stuff and got some unique
views so we'll definitely bring you back
and i appreciate your time
thanks pop i had a great time thanks for
having me on all right buddy talk soon